we do we are with ashita after her first
victory at the US championships ashita
welcome back yesterday you were very
close to getting that first Victory
finally today you got it your thoughts
and your feelings right
now um yeah it's definitely great to get
a win especially this late in the
tournament after yesterday's roller
coaster 6-hour game um but I felt good
coming into today after my long game
against Arena yesterday given that I
usually like at least in the past couple
of years have lost against her so the
fact that I was able to hold on to that
losing position and even have chances to
win it felt pretty good yesterday
absolutely and today was a very long
piece of uh theoretical preparation tell
us a little bit about that you guys got
this position and it felt like you were
still in theory but then she played this
move Queen to E7 the novelty did you
know anything about it
I actually didn't look at this
particular line too much so I was
actually on my own uh when she castled
cuz I know usually black is supposed to
go Bishop B6 um there's a bunch of games
there I think um but when she castled I
knew this was a little inaccurate and so
I just played and was kind of focusing
on the dark squares with like Knight B3
Queen
C3 um and I I felt like things started
to go wrong I wasn't sure here actually
whether to trade Rooks or play rookie
one but I was just like let's just keep
Rooks and play on in the middle game and
it paid off it definitely did pay off
because your Aon became such a
tremendous weapon in the position uh
forcing a lot of her resources to stay
close to it and that's exactly the thing
that gave you the resource that gave you
the victory in this one ashita
congratulations go enjoy your rest day
and uh we will we will'll see you in a
couple of
days thank you our congratulations as
well